jonathan connue raconte une histoire
elle est incroyable ok mais après je
raconte mon histoire c'est celle de
fiennes saut et franchement c'est un
truc de dingue d'accord dans mon
histoire vous désir des jeunes et non
c'est gentil merci monsieur dans mon
pays on a une choucroute de la mer sur
son livre simple après flic un peu me
mettais en 6 merci au revoir donc dans
mon histoire je tombe secondes
c'est très important les garçons ça
bosse de koné garcia suis tellement donc
dans mon histoire
en fait ça va encore mais dont nous
raconte une histoire de ouf apparemment
ils ont même à commencer donc si tu peux
moi pareil hier j'ai vu julie gayet la
voile c'est une amie elle m'a raconté
une anecdote mon poste j'ai pas dormi de
la nuit
oui il arrive on s'appelle on s'appelle
rick quelqu'un peut il arriver jusque là
il arrive vous avez su que je parte avec
tessinois mais pas du tout pas du tout
tu peux rester donc je te disais dans
mon histoire
oh non j'ai vite je dois retrouver
cyprien c'est une gentille ludovic tu as
une minute
j'écoute ton histoire il faut que tu
sois court et concis donc
excusez moi il est midi comme chaque
jour à la même heure nous allons
observer une minute de silence en la
mémoire de johnny hallyday nous manque
tellement soir
[Musique]